[Music]
so they're gonna bulldoze the little
house in the Prairie the classic
children's books by Laura Ingalls Wilder
are the latest works to run afoul of the
left-wing Cultural Revolution now in
progress the Association for library
service to children just renamed it's
Laura Ingalls Wilder award to the
children's literature Legacy Award the
reason you knew this is that the Little
House on the Prairie books apparently
somehow promote racism sexism and many
other isms every ISM you can imagine
well so Francis is one of the smartest
people who works in TV by the way she
hosts after the Bell and Fox Business
she's the author of lessons from the
Prairie and she played Cassandra Ingalls
on Little House on the Prairie on
television so she's well situated to
respond to that she joins us tonight
what do you make of what do you make of
this charge I don't even understand it
it's astonishing so when I was writing
that book you just saw lessons from the
Prairie I reread all of the books and it
is astonishing how equal women are in
these books because to their own
physical detriment they are risking life
and limb on the pioneering just
alongside the men the women described
are working outside the home they're
selling things this was written by a
woman and they say that the book
represents outdated cultural ideas while
I was looking at some of the other
winners on their list
growing up in slavery stories of young
slaves as told by themselves I bet you
there are some outdated notions about
culture in that book as well yes I which
is why we read these historical accounts
to educate ourselves and understand our
culture where we came from mistakes
we've made in the past strengths of our
founding you would read both of these
works and here this is a strong female
author by the way it's a lead female
character even the show you know it
Hollywood had a lead female character
the me2 movement it's all about women
aren't getting the roles in Hollywood
that's part of it that they aren't
getting a fair shake here this is like
an old woman project basically if you
look at Laura Ingalls Wilder writing
about her family about her mother's life
on the frontier and I mean there are
scenes where it ma is building a house
with pot they dropped the log on mas leg
she continues to build the house with
her husband just the two of them
with a broken foot I mean talk about
equal rights I'm not sure I want those
equal rights but that's equal right I
think it's just the stoppage talked
about my conclusion is no these people
didn't read the books they just didn't
read the books the revolution is not
only sinister it's dumb it's but she
made some characteristically very smart
insightful points Melissa France is
great to see you thank you you too thank
you